hey linda we are looking at a photograph  of a man smiling into the camera with a  drawing on his hand i think it's  waves and this is called daisyroth he's  one of the top professors at stanford  university  and a pioneer in the field of  optogenetics can you tell us what you  found out in your interview with him  he has a very unusual brain you know he  can  focus and read a whole group of words  a whole block of words old pages and  repeat it immediately  and also he's very unusual also as a  researcher and he always tries to find  out  where our feelings coming from and also  how our brain is working  in private life he's also unusual  because he has five children  his wife is also scientist and they are  taking care of the children by  themselves  and he tries to carve out every day an  hour  to have deep thinking and he thinks  that's  very important to be a good scientist